when the intergovernmental panel on
climate change released its highly
anticipated report on global warming in
early august un secretary general
antonio guterres declared it nothing
less than a code red for humanity
insisting that the alarm bells are
deafening and the evidence is
irrefutable greenhouse gas emissions
from fossil fuel burning and
deforestation are choking our planet and
putting billions of people at immediate
risk guterres's code red language was
echoed by the press and activists some
of whom called humanity guilty as hell
of climate crimes others prophesied that
the climate news is only going to get
worse and that the choice before us was
immediately passing the green new deal
or death roger pelkey jr a professor of
environmental studies at the university
of colorado writes that such reactions
are not only wrong but irresponsible
pelkey believes that temperatures are
rising in response to human activity but
that the alarmism that dominates the
discussion is counterproductive
nowhere does the ipcc report say that
billions of people are at immediate risk
he says stressing the gap between what's
actually in the report and the highly
politicized way we discuss climate
change reason talked with pelkey about
why apocalyptic scenarios about
temperature change are severely mistaken
how the planet is getting more
hospitable to human life and how ongoing
incremental improvements in energy
technologies will almost certainly lead
to a brighter cleaner future for all
roger pelkey junior thanks for talking
to reason nick it's great to be here
okay so in a uh in a uh a response to
the ipcc report that dropped uh recently
uh you wrote that you know this prompted
a flurry of interpretations and yes spin
and i'm quoting you you say the
secretary general of the united nations
warned of and you're quoting him now a
code red for humanity the alarm bells
are deafening and the evidence is
irrefutable greenhouse gas emissions
from fossil fuel burning and
deforestation are choking our planet and
putting billions of people at immediate
risk you respond to this at your sub
stack saying not only is this wrong it
is irresponsible
let's start with what's wrong with that
um how is what the secretary general of
the un the organization that oversees
the ipcc um what is he getting wrong
yeah the the part of that that i think
is is most troubling is is the
fear-inducing statement that that people
billions of people around the world are
at immediate risk
um the reality is um and according to
statistics uh kept by the u.n
the world is actually much safer place
than it um has been in the past when it
comes to extreme weather and climate
vulnerability has gone down dramatically
put a you know can you put some numbers
or or kind of facts on that what do you
when you say you know because everybody
you know kind of agrees unless unless
you deny global warming temperatures
have gone up uh you hear a lot of
stories about extreme weather events
we'll get into that in a little bit but
um it when you say the planet is you
know people are at less risk it means
fewer people are dying from
weather-related events yeah i mean think
of it like this in the 1920s 100 years
ago
let's say there's two billion people on
the planet and millions
of people died from extreme weather and
climate events millions literally um
today there's um you know
seven to eight billion people on the
planet and um
every death is a tragedy of course but
we see thousands of deaths from from
extreme weather and climate um going
from millions to thousands is a drop um
you know of several orders of magnitude
it is one of the greatest
scientific technological and policy
success stories
of humanity in the last century so so to
claim that uh billions of people are at
immediate risk is simply scientifically
empirically factually incorrect okay
what what else is wrong
in the uh you know the the un secretary
general's uh announcement of a code red
for humanity
yeah i think the idea that a an ipcc
report um is a some sort of a threshold
or a um announcing new information the
reality is the ipcc which is an
important institution it's been around
for for more than three decades if it
didn't exist we'd have to recreate it um
but its message to um to policymakers
for that time has been largely um solid
and consistent over that time
and it its job is to assess a you know a
sprawling vast scientific literature
um but there's really nothing new there
so so and and i know you know
politicians and policy makers like to
use reports as
a newsworthy event to try to you know
motivate this or that action um but the
the the idea that the ipcc report when
it came out um was giving new
information that we didn't have the day
before or honestly 10 years ago or 20
years ago um you know it's put finer
points and more precision
on and there's new science of course but
the core messages haven't changed so the
idea advanced by policymakers that that
this all right finally this report is
the trigger um i think it's a misleading
interpretation of how science actually
works is that um is that also true of
the report the ipcc uh reporter update
that came out out in the fall of 2018
which gave rise to the
um you know to the mantra or the trope
that we have 12 years to fix the
planet's climate otherwise we're done
you know this was popularized by people
like alexandria queso cortez and greta
tunberg but also joe biden when he was
running for president talked about how
we only have x number of years to go
before we you know we lose the planet
yeah i mean deadline ism you know it's
not unique to climate change um
certainly um and it's it's a common um
trope in in political debates to try to
motivate people to action climate change
is particularly difficult because it's
not particularly amenable to deadlineism
the climate is is changing we're
responsible
it's incremental it's it's not um a
sudden you know threshold type issue
there is some science about tipping
points and so on but the reality is i
mean we just look back over the last 30
years um that's a good good metric for
how the next 30 years are going to be so
the ipcc has has generally
been responsible in not
stating deadlines like you hear
politicians and advocates state but the
ipcc does sometimes lend itself to that
interpretation
so that that 12 years you know until the
end of time from the 1.5 degree report
um you know that that was a creation of
the media advocates um citing the ipcc
the ipcc never said you know we have 10
years till catastrophe or whatever right
and i mean part of that uh just to uh
get a sense of part of it is that there
there's a belief or or you know that's
widespread among activists as well as
people politicians
uh and people in the media that it's
kind of like the the environment is kind
of like uh cooking an egg where at a
certain point the egg you know the white
gets you know solidifies and it and it
turns white and the yolk gets cooked and
like it can't be uncooked that is kind
of the wrong analogy right for the
environment there isn't a point at least
from the science where you can say okay
now we're done it's just more that
there's a a
ramp up right or or
uh you know incremental change yeah i
mean it's i mean i think there was a
time magazine
cover with an egg and a frying pan that
your comments reminded me of but but
both
climate change
and successful climate policy um are our
long-term
incremental
effects if you look at sea level rise
sea level rise is not something that oh
my gosh we're gonna wake up tomorrow and
you know there's a meter more
ocean out there um you know it's it's
millimeters per year basically forever
um and so climate policy decarbon is
decarbonizing the economy is not
something that oh we wake up tomorrow
and all of a sudden you know there's a
nuclear power plant on every corner it's
it's incremental it's it's steady slow
change the the analogy i often use it's
it's like uh the advance in human life
stands
right it doesn't happen overnight it's a
it's a decades even century-long process
so i think this is this is one of the
challenges with deadline ism
is that in the context of climate change
it
we don't have deadlines for
the effects of climate change we don't
have deadlines for successful climate
policy and that's really hard to square
with uh with the science when when
advocates keep pushing for you know we
have 100 days we have 12 months we have
12 years and so on so is that i mean
does the science refute the the kind of
hockey stick paradigm that you know
you're going along you're going along
and like things are going up a little
bit a little bit and then suddenly they
shoot way up that uh people like michael
mann the scientist or al gore you know
and it seems like a million years ago
but in talking about inc an inconvenient
truth whether it's the book or the movie
um that hockey stick paradigm is just
not accurate is is that safe to say
well i mean it depends what you mean by
the parrot i mean unfortunately
or unfortunately um i'm not you know an
expert in the you know paleo climate
world and so that's you know a very
long-term perspective and yeah and
there's been debates about the the
proper use of um you know hockey stick
like graphs there's one that appears
it's the first graph in the summary for
policy makers in the current ipcc report
but i think you know where it has
relevance is in the context of extreme
events
the idea that we're seeing an abrupt
change in the number of hurricanes or
the number of floods um you know that
that marks a departure from from what
we've seen in the past
and that's that's not
supported
by the evidence so what is the evidence
then say you know with things like
uh hurricanes and uh you know uh and
storms like that what what is going on
yeah the first thing to to for people to
to to understand is that extreme weather
is a big category it's got a lot of
things in it
it's a little bit like disease
right we wouldn't talk about disease
in general what we do is we talk about
heart disease or cancer or covet
and you know we have treatments specific
to disease so the ipcc actually has um
done a very nice job in
summarizing the
the evidence and the literature on a
wide range of extreme events and i mean
just to pick several um heat waves are
one where the ipcc has
explained that we've seen an increase in
the number of heat waves and they have
attributed that means that they have you
know determined that the causality
behind that increase in heat waves um to
some significant degree
is human
um and of course there's factors like
urbanization and so on that also
contribute to heatwave um extreme
precipitation is another one the ipcc
has identified an upwards trend in in
some places around the world and
attributed that to human causes
the ipcc is also
very explicit that extreme precipitation
is not necessarily the same thing as
flooding
there's a lot of reasons for that but if
you want to look at trends in flooding
look at flooding and the ipcc very
responsibly has said if you look around
the world in certain places and you know
there's up trends and downtrends but
there's no overall signal
there's nothing overall to attribute to
human causes hurricanes which is um you
know the name for
the broader category tropical cyclones
the ipcc again very responsibly says
on a century time scale looking back on
planet earth they don't detect trends
it's very hard to detect trends and if
it's hard to detect trends they can't be
very large
is that you know to go back so fewer
fewer people are dying from weather
events like hurricanes or you know
tsunamis or whatever
but there's more damage caused by
hurricanes right because we have built
up along coasts and things like that or
is is that is that a source of confusion
then
yeah there's a lot of confused stuff so
the the the decline in deaths um is
really easy for people to see and to
understand because it's you know sharp
going way down and it's it's down both
in absolute numbers but also in terms of
the proportion of people on the planet
economic damage is a little bit more
complicated and difficult to understand
because the absolute costs of damage is
going up there's no doubt about it and
why is it going up because we have more
buildings we have more property we have
more wealth we have more stuff that's
exposed
to to extreme weather or hurricanes you
know whatever it happens to be so we
would expect as we get wealthier that
we're going to see
an absolute increase in costs
what
you can do though is you can say well
let's see how damage has increased as a
proportion of our wealth
um and
given that and we do this all the time
in all sorts of contexts
and usually gdp is in the denominator
but there's more sophisticated ways to
to look at um
disaster losses but once we do that we
actually see and this is there's a large
literature um this shouldn't be
particularly controversial um that the
the cost of extreme weather events in
climate events has actually gone down as
a proportion of our wealth that's
fantastic news and the reason is we're
we're less vulnerable than we used to be
it's
we know how to build structures
that can withstand
extreme weather and if you look around
the world particularly in poor countries
or countries that used to be poor
the
decline in vulnerability is just
remarkable again it's a great scientific
success story and that means that people
are less likely to die because of you
know a hurricane
you know a flood a landslide something
like that yeah i mean it's there's a lot
of moving parts in um in in risk but you
know among them are our weather
forecasts and warnings and the ability
for people to actually respond when they
hear a forecast or a warning i mean if
you take a look at the indian ocean
basin for example at bangladesh and
india in the 1960s routinely tens of
thousands of people would die when a
cyclone hit often unwarned and people
were you know didn't didn't get out of
the way um
today um you know fortunately um
tens maybe hundreds might die in an
event that would have been tens of
thousands you know 50 years ago
it's a true it's a remarkable success
story i can't i can't even overstate how
how um
how great this uh application of science
and technology has actually been it's
it's like you know it's similar to
vaccination right it's
most people don't know what the world
looked like before we had vaccines um
and most people don't know what the
world looked like before we had uh you
know this great reduction in
vulnerability to weather events you know
in the ipcc report
you
and in your critique of it you talk
about how they they lay out a bunch of
different scenarios and they're you know
there's essentially five major scenarios
um can you talk about the range of them
and then the way in which um the uh the
authors of the report either do or don't
assign probabilities of you know that
this one scenario is going to be the
outcome what's the what's the range of
scenarios and um you know how how
seriously should we take different you
know different scenarios
yeah so scenario planning is is a really
important tool for policy analysis goes
back to the 1960s and and the reason why
we use scenarios um is that the
long-term future is is basically
unpredictable
we've learned this over and over um even
aspects of the near term future are
unpredictable
so for
you know 30 years since the ipcc started
it
has used scenarios to um
to look into how climate change might
manifest itself decades and towards the
end of the century and even longer
to produce those scenarios you need to
know something about well how many
people are going to be on the planet
what's our economy going to look like
what kind of energy sources are we going
to use how efficient will we be
many of these variables are very
difficult or impossible to predict so
the ipcc has used a range
which makes a lot of sense
there's been a debate in the ipcc and in
the community
do we want to have a scenario that is
our best guess
as to where we're going in the future
or do we just want to present them as
hey here's a whole bunch of plausible
futures policy makers you can figure out
you know how you want to deal with that
the advantage of having a best guess
scenario is that you can use that for
things like cost benefit analysis or
cost effectiveness you can say well if
this is where we're headed and we alter
course what are the economic benefits of
doing so um
and that that can be traced to cost
benefit analysis which goes back to the
1980s
the problem is and i think you can see
this right away is if we can't predict
the future
um
identifying a best guess is a pretty
um risky enterprise because we might you
know we're likely to be wrong in our
best guess we've always seen that so the
ipcc has bounced back and forth between
these different approaches
in its recent
report
before the current one 2013
it did identify a scenario as
what i call a reference scenario you
know the best guess um often also called
business as usual
and the current report abandoned that
approach
and so um
this makes it i think difficult for
people to understand
um
you know what the report's actually
saying uh because if you provide a range
um
people will interpret that as some sort
of
set of likelihoods
and you know media and advocacy loves to
focus at the top of the range um and so
my critique um
with colleagues um and you know we
publish this in the literature
is that the the ipcc it's its upper end
scenarios are simply no longer
can be considered plausible what what
are the upper end scenarios you know
in terms by 2050 or 2100 what are they
predicting in terms of increase in
temperature and attendant effects
yeah so so the the upper end scenarios
and they have technical names that are
attached to them
project something like a four to five
degree celsius temperature change by
2100 dramatic dramatic climate effects
um
and so
and to contrast that with um
more plausible scenarios um that are you
know the ipcc calls intermediate
scenarios these are more like three
degrees
celsius um i think the best the the the
best guess for the intermediate scenario
of the current ipcc is 2.7 degrees so
it's something like you know almost
twice as much warming um overall by 2100
these scenarios are implausible and you
know the short story is they're grounded
in socioeconomic assumptions that
it's not our planet so for example one
of the assumptions of these extreme
scenarios is that we are going to
abandon all of our energy sources
except coal
we're going to replace wind and solar
and nuclear and gas and even gasoline
with coal
and uh we're going to consume six more
than six times per person the amount of
coal in 2100 than we do today right and
that is that's implausible partly
because you've written and others have
uh noted that we probably have either
reached the peak use of coal uh or it's
or we're just about to and it's actually
going to be declining yeah the scholar
who
really has done the most work on this is
my colleague justin ritchie um in
british columbia
and
he identified an assumption of the
scenarios goes back to the 1990s that
that assumed that
the assumption in this scenario is that
we're going to learn how to extract
fossil fuels and by extracting them it's
going to be cheaper and easier and it's
going to be like a avalanche going down
a hill we're just going to do more and
more and more of it it's called learning
by doing
that's not how things have panned out
and unfortunately unfortunately for the
ipcc and for climate policy that
assumption has been baked into the
scenarios really all of the scenarios um
that underpin
what ultimately is really really
important climate modeling work and so
on projecting the future
the result is we get these upper end
scenarios that once were deemed the most
probable
um that have been the focus of a lot of
policy debate of advocacy and the
problem is they they they project a
future um
that is is not one that we're headed to
we can say pretty confidently can we say
it's possible but very unlikely
i mean you know it's conceivable right
yeah i mean i think
when we do scenario planning we
certainly want to do what are called
exploratory scenarios
right so it would be perfectly
reasonable for a scientist to say you
know what what would happen
if an asteroid like the one that
apparently got you know took care of the
dinosaurs hit the earth in in 2030.
that's very different than saying hey an
asteroid's going to hit the earth in
2030.
and so yes it's really important and you
know climate modelers will will tell you
and they tell me all the time
i really like extreme scenarios because
that helps me to separate a signal
of greenhouse gas forcing for example
from the noise of natural variability
great that makes a lot of sense
the problem is is when we conflate
exploratory
extreme scenarios with
plausibility or probability a little bit
like the at the asteroid example
so what out of the out of the scenarios
that are kind of put forth in the ipcc
report um they don't ascribe a
particular likelihoods right like they
don't say you know what this one is
eighty percent likely to come true this
one is five percent or anything um
right and and you actually you hail that
as a uh as a sign of progress
yes because in the in the previous
report the 2013 report there was a
scenario identified as a reference you
know the most likely scenario which was
the most extreme
in the current report they they very
explicitly say we don't assign
likelihoods to these different scenarios
the problem is when you go into the meat
of the report not all scenarios are
treated equally right and you point out
in a chart where you've referenced that
the
number of references to the more extreme
scenarios than to the more moderate or
the i guess more optimistic ones what
did you find there
yeah i mean if you look at the report
you just do a simple you know how much
where's the focus of attention where
where are they summarizing the
literature more than half of the
mentions of
scenarios are two implausible extreme
scenarios
so it has this built in and there's a
long history here
and it is i think it's an accurate
reflection of the scientific literature
um that's out there there is an
overwhelming emphasis on the extreme
implausible scenarios
the problem is this is a report for
policy makers
and it gives the impression
that again you know even without saying
it up front that you know this is where
the world is headed or the you know the
interpretation that you get from looking
at a report with 50
extreme scenarios is is a built-in
um you know catastrophe bias i guess i
would call it in the report is that you
know is it because the scientists
putting it together the researchers
putting this together believe that or i
mean you know how is is there bias among
researchers to
you know kind of gravitate towards
extreme scenarios yeah and and i would
there is definitely a bias and it's not
you know i would hate to disappoint
people but it's not a political bias and
it's not a an advocacy bias it's a bias
that for the purposes of climate
modeling extreme scenarios are really
useful
they tell you something about the
science
and this is this is where something went
wrong there was a short circuit in the
ipcc process in the in the
development and prioritization of the
scenarios that underpin a lot of climate
research
decisions were made literally
10 15 years ago about these scenarios
apparently with no assessment of policy
relevance or likelihood
so so we find ourselves in 2021 with
this vast literature this this
incredible report that hundreds of
scientists spent time on
and the foundation that it's built on
these scenarios never went
underwent um evaluation for plausibility
um or probability so so you know in one
sense it's not surprising then that that
whatever cultural and
scientific factors went into the
selection and prioritization of the
scenarios um
you know we can explain it but it's it's
not surprising then that the report
isn't as policy focused as we might hope
it would be in 2021 leading to a media
discussion advocacy um that centers on
these extreme scenarios that are that
are highly improbable
so now we're getting towards that uh
notion that this report is uh you know
or the the secretary general's uh
characterization of it is not only wrong
but is irresponsible it's kind of the
report i mean is it is it right to say
the report is somewhat irresponsible
then or is it really our treatment of it
i mean it's both i mean the the the
working so the ipcc has three working
groups you know the first one which this
is this report is the physical science
of climate change the second one is
impacts and the third is economics um
and you know i've had discussions with
with ipcc
um leaders and folks you know in the
past week and i'm routinely told hey
it's not our job in working group one to
assess scenarios to evaluate their
likelihood or probability and and for me
that's
um
you know that's a problem for the ipcc
it's a problem for all of us because it
lends itself to an uncorrectable
um
set of misinterpretations so when the
the head of the un uh says it's code red
for humanity yeah and that's you know
that's not correct that's not what the
ipcc says but if you look at the report
and you say oh my gosh look at all these
extreme scenarios um we're in a
situation where you know part of the
ipcc's job is to evaluate the literature
and so it it would have been much more
helpful for the world if the ipcc had an
ability to say all right
we're going to ring fence these extreme
implausible scenarios we'll put them in
a chapter called you know exploratory
scenarios something like that um it says
upfront uh in the report
these extreme scenarios are
its languages low likelihood
and then it ignores that throughout the
report so
so what are the what are the in in your
um kind of analysis uh or in the report
itself what is the most likely scenario
or the more likely scenarios you know
where will we be in 2100
and what will that mean for our
day-to-day life well we you know we're
not we're not going to be at you know
five or seven degrees hotter celsius
where are we going to be and what will
that mean
yeah so it's important i mean we have to
distinguish between you know what
how how much co2 emissions are going to
be put out and then what's the
corresponding temperature there's still
scenarios where we could have high
temperature change
or large climate change
for reasons independent of of carbon
dioxide emissions
so uh and unfortunately those scenarios
aren't you know aren't present in the in
the current report um
but
assessments so the first thing to say is
prediction is a mugs game
it's uh
anyone who thinks they can tell you what
the world's gonna look like in 2100 you
know they're probably selling you
something um but but we can do some
things and there are some quantitative
ways to evaluate scenarios and one of
the things we've done is if you take the
scenarios that were produced several
decades ago they project out to 2100
they give us you know now 15 or 20 years
of data
on how the world has actually evolved
for you know 20 of the of the century so
we can take
the the evidence from the real world and
say all right let's match that up with
this
massive body of scenarios the ipcc and
its
2013 report has almost 1200 scenarios
so we can say all right of those 1200
scenarios
which ones best match
what's happened in the last 20 years
and so we've done that and so we can
throw out you know literally you know
700 or 900 scenarios depending on how
how closely you want it to match
then we can say well what are those
scenarios project
into the
future into you know out to 2100
and what we get when we take that subset
that looks like the real world so far um
they project about 2.2 degrees warming
by 20 100. and this is very much in line
with um a lot of the the physical
sciences
literature look and other work looking
at current policies and projecting that
forward
it's still climate change
the problem doesn't go away it it
doesn't become invisible
but what it does say is that yeah these
these extreme scenarios are really
implausible it also says that the
the the three degree projection um
that that now is you know people are
talking about um
is likely a worst case scenario
not not a central tendency um and also i
guess i'll say that you know if our goal
is to limit climate change to a two
degree change or even 1.5 degree we're
actually in better position than we
thought we would have been
10 or 15 years ago and that's good news
why is 1.5 or 2 degrees you know 1.5
degrees 2 degrees why people seem to
catch on these numbers
is there anything magic or or you know
particular
in those figures or is it just that's
what people latch on to
it's the nature of politics and policy
to focus on simple targets and
timetables the two degree
temperature target comes from
work of
william nordhaus in particular an
economist won the nobel prize
in the 1970s who
looked at earlier climatological
research
focused on temperatures in
central england
and
that the the the discovery there was
that well historically temperatures
fluctuated to plus or minus one degree
from some baseline so um
nordhouse said well it looks like two
degrees is the threshold within which
humanity can operate
um nice round number and it kind of
propagated through the literature
and eventually became adopted as a as a
target um
it was realized um at some point that
that two degrees was a threshold the
world would um exceed decades into the
future it did not lend itself to
um targets and timetables sort of
approaches and so 1.5 degrees which is
right you know on the on the horizon um
was proposed as part of the paris
agreement um and it was you know more an
aspirational target
but it that lends itself you know much
more to immediate targets and timetable
sort of discussions so so the answer is
yeah there's a pseudo scientific
you know background to it but it's it's
much more arbitrary in terms of um
supporting policy discussions
um is is part of the climate change
discussion and the way to deal with it
and i want to get into that in a minute
but you know as part of it it's it it
seems like people are coming at it with
very different um uh kind of end states
or or presumptions uh where it's you
know the main thing is to keep the
global temperature the average median
mean temperature at a at or below a
certain level that's one camp and so
everything has to go towards that and
then the other and you've kind of
articulated this where you know the real
measure is you know are we able to have
support more or if more or fewer people
on the planet or more fewer people dying
because of weather um is is that part of
what's going on here is that people are
talking past each other
yeah absolutely i mean climate change um
and mike hume who's um
a researcher at cambridge has written a
wonderful book called why we disagree
about climate change but but climate
change has has
developed into i mean it's sort of like
a christmas tree and everybody gets to
hang their ornament on it and it it
really now encompasses discussions of
all of human and ecological
status of the planet and yes for some
people they boil it down to a simple
temperature target
for others it's about energy access and
justice
around the world for others as you say
it's about vulnerability and exposure
and risk for still others it's about
particulate pollution and we could go on
and on and on and so so it is a
sprawling encompassing
topic that you know we really have to
take apart if we want to talk about
specific policies um it is it is a
symbol um you know climate change is a
symbol would i mean is is it wrong to
suggest that this may be far outside
your uh area of expertise or interest
but you know has it become and and i
don't mean this pejoratively but almost
the theological debate where it's really
about our relationship to you know to
this life and the afterlife or what of
the future
um and as a result we're we're all
bringing very different conceptions of
what is good and just and proper and as
a result it it's hard to you know even
have meaningful conversations with
people that you disagree with yeah i
mean i think yeah i think that's fair
and i also think that that that has been
the the tenor of environmental debates
and discussions you know
going back decades and longer even we go
back to the population resources debates
of the 70s
you know with the carrying capacity of
the earth and so on
ultimately
the debates we have about climate change
are debates about how we want as a
global community to go into the future
and with all of the complexities and all
the baggage and all the politics and all
that so of course it is and how could it
not be
but it does make it very difficult to
have healthy productive debates because
policy making
is precise it's incremental it occurs in
different places on different scales and
policy making is not in response to big
global
views about how we should go into the
future it's it's very precise so there
is that that disconnect that makes it
difficult so let's talk a little bit
about what your ideas about what what
are the best ways to deal with climate
change and you unambiguously
you know you believe that climate change
has happened you know that climate
change is happening and that you know
human activity is is a major cause of it
um the ipcc report says you know over
the past 50 years there has been a
significant increase
in temperatures um you know when going
back to the mid 19th century that you
know a lot of it has happened since
1970.
um that is primarily that's that's a
function of human activity right
yeah yeah so i think i mean let me just
say i mean the ipcc reports i mean we
can criticize them and um they can do
better and they should do better but
over the last 30 years they provide a
really important touchstone for the core
findings of climate science that haven't
changed so
yeah and and i guess one of the things
and this is where it gets difficult and
in your work i mean you do some stuff
for kind of lay readers at your sub
stack and and in the popular press and
then there's technical debates so you
know it you know there there is there's
a level of uh you know of kind of
expertise that you can you can find in
in your work in other people's work
um but then what what are the primary um
ways forward like what what is going to
happen like between now and 2100 and i
realize you know uh prediction is a mugs
game but what are the main outcomes that
we need to minimize or or to redirect um
what what's the problem if we don't do
anything you know what
what's the problem going to look like in
2100
yeah i mean and the way that i like to
to frame it is
the best way to to
predict the future is to create that
future and we create the future by
making decisions we take one fork in a
road versus another fork in the world
and if we look at the climate problem um
and the broader climate issue i mean we
can there's really two two parallel
tracks um that have
developed over time one is called
mitigation which is reducing the human
effect on climate um the other is
adaptation which is reducing the
climate's effect on humans um
and
there are a lot of reasons and i've you
know i wrote a book about this why we
might want to decarbonize the global
economy beyond just
global temperature change
i mean one thing to realize is that
there are still
large numbers of people on this planet
that don't enjoy
the kind of energy access that you and i
have
and
if we look you know going forward one
thing that i think is a pretty safe bet
there's going to be more energy
consumption worldwide going forward as
far as the eye can see
until you know the world
people around the world reach the level
of energy access that people in europe
or north america or south america and
this is a well-recognized paradigm i
mean there's two points there's one just
a lot of people are really not on the
energy grid yet but then also as energy
gets more efficient it isn't like okay
we'll use less we actually use more
because it's cheaper and we can do more
things with right so so for all those
reasons we're going to be using more
energy and and energy
production as as we know can be dirty
can have environmental consequences
setting aside
climate change particulate air pollution
from burning things like coal or um or
even natural gas
leads to millions of deaths around the
world so so the the idea of you know
moving towards cleaner energy
it makes a lot of sense for a lot of
reasons and so um
you know the good news is that
the the energy system has been
decarbonizing for almost a century
um so what we're talking about with
climate policy is accelerating a trend
that's already in place um on purpose
and we do this all the time we want so
that another you know
a site the same example human lifespans
we want human lifespans to be longer
because we like living
and we want disease um to be reduced and
so we do that incrementally diseased by
disease over time and we see progress
decarbonization is very similar right we
we make incremental progress and i think
the news is actually really good on you
know the costs of solar and wind energy
um there are of course debates over
nuclear and you know whether people fear
nuclear more than they fear climate
change or vice versa um but the trend in
mitigation um is a positive one um it
will
will countries reach net zero by 2050 i
mean it's a huge endeavor um but you
know one thing we can say is it's front
and center in our policy debates right
now so so i think we have good reason to
be optimistic what is can i ask from a
uh kind of doctrine or libertarian
perspective uh what is what what are the
prime uh
you know the motive forces in
decarbonization is it
um a uh is it a kind of um market-driven
innovative search for more efficient uh
and energy-producing forms of of energy
or is it
uh government policies where you know
people on some level representative
bodies have said we want cleaner air or
we want less carbon we want this we want
that um you know is that you know what
what are the
what are the forces that have driven the
decarbonization
yeah you know i tell my my phd students
to to aware questions that have an ore
in the middle
the answer is always yes yeah if you
look at the energy
economy which is a significant part of
the global economy something you know
depending on how you measure it like 10
or 20 percent
um
it is a complicated mix of market and
government forces um and when i say
government you know the saudi arabian
government is different than the united
states government it's different than
the chinese government so um the energy
economy is you know the pacemaker is
technological change
and economics
so all things equal people tend to
prefer spending less money on energy
than more money and that provides a very
powerful motivation for technological
progress
governments
play a role both in you know on the
regulatory side
but also on the innovation side
if you look at you know look at your
iphone
you know there's nice
graphs that show you know a lot of the
technologies came from you know private
and public sector
intersection it's the same with energy
fracking is a great example
folks at the breakthrough institute in
particular have documented how um you
know that was an overnight success story
with 30 years of you know government
investment behind it uh collaborating
with the private sector
you can't really tease that apart
so i'm very much of the view that
if if we want to accelerate the rate of
decarbonization then we need to have
market ready deployable energy
technologies at scale
that will lead to lower costs for
consumers than the ones we have now
um that's that's going to
both support decarbonization but also
support the politics of decarbonization
yeah as you can see we see this right
now
joe biden is is wrestling with um four
dollar
a gallon gasoline
and it's a political issue and um for
people who are wealthy whether it's you
know three dollars and fifty cents or
four dollars doesn't matter but for a
lot of people that's a that's a
significant difference it affects their
life so um
so being able to to produce lower-cost
sources of energy and then
technologies that consume energy
is how we're going to accelerate
decarbonization so what are the best
ways forward because i'm old enough as i
suspect you are to remember the 70s and
there was a hell of a lot of money and
time taxpayer money spent on developing
alternative fuels or synthetic fuels etc
because people were tired of the good
old odd even you know gas pump days and
things like that
um what is the bet what are the best
policies for government to pursue to
help kind of speed along the
decarbonization as opposed to kind of do
political favoritism where it you know i
mean shifting if we shift to electric
cars but the electricity is all
generated by burning coal you know it
kind of makes you you know feel morally
superior in your prius or something like
that or in your tesla but you're not
really fixing the problem what what are
the best things that government can be
doing to kind of speed up uh
decarbonization yeah and and ultimately
this is this is a challenge of
innovation um and and
i recommend let's look at innovation
success stories for issues that are
similar to the climate issue long-term
incremental but we want to we know where
we want to go and the two best examples
are health and agriculture
the the the agricultural innovation
system is uh
just like i described a complex brew of
public private sector yeah is there
political favoritism and cronyism and
you know failures in agriculture of
course
but undeniably the world and you know
the united states
as well has continued to improve its
productivity in agriculture
if you look at health you know again are
there
are there market failures are there
public failures in health policy
absolutely um
and
but if you look at the long term
the the improvement in human lifespans
and the reduction of disease is
undeniable um the fact that the united
states even before covid started to see
a dip in lifespans mainly because of
opioids and
substance abuse issues
was identified as a problem
but over the long term we have good
examples of how the public and private
sectors can work together to
accelerate progress towards a target so
is that something like operation warp
speed i i guess in a generic way maybe
that's the wrong way to look at it you
know something where the government um
you know issues a bounty or a reward for
you know if if you develop something
that passes this threshold you will pay
you or will subsidize you yeah i mean
prizes and awards have been um
looked at in as part of um you know
innovation policy and they can be
effective um in a lot of respects i mean
one thing for people to understand is
that that energy
excuse me energy investment by the
federal government um
has not typically been that large uh
compared to say how much is spent on
defense or health research um
so so
one thing that could be done would be to
expand and we see you know calls for
this with you know an arpa-e and so on
but to expand the ecosystem of of energy
not just r d r d is important but the
whole innovation ecosystem that to be
able to bring things to market to test
things out to see what works see what
doesn't work
we're really bad at picking
technological winners um
in um because we you know the future's
hard to predict so the more
opportunities you have to create winners
uh the more winners you'll have and of
course
innovation policy um is is littered with
failures um
and and that that's gonna go you know so
so is is drug research um it's littered
with drugs that never make it to market
or potential drugs um so we should
expect there's going to be failures but
but we have um
we have a pretty good ability to
accelerate innovation when we direct
our attention towards that so i mean the
climate debate the focus is on
temperatures
and carbon dioxide emissions um and i
i've recommended it's a little bit more
technical but i've focused on rates of
decarbonization so carbon dioxide per
unit of gdp
we want our economy to get bigger and we
want carbon dioxide to go down
and so we can actually
better manage to that sort of a target
than say you know very abstract
temperature target and that lends itself
to um evaluating the success or failure
of alternative uh innovation policies is
there a role for nuclear energy i mean
you talked about uh wind and solar
hydroelectric power is also you know
booming in certain parts of the world
and typically as a kind of state
enterprise
nuclear power if you if you go back to
the early 60s i always
find it fascinating that the
foundational documents of both the young
americans for freedom a right-wing
student group in the early 60s and
students for democratic society a
left-wing group and founded in the early
60s both take for granted in their
foundational documents that we will have
limitless pollution free
essentially uh cheap if not absolutely
free energy provided by nuclear power
plants
obviously that hasn't quite worked out
countries like france
still produce a majority of their
electricity or energy through nuclear
power other places in the u.s were
decommissioning stuff germany you know
getting rid of it what is the role of
nuclear power in uh you know in a
decarbonized global
scenario yeah so i think one thing to
understand in energy policy that um
different energy technologies are like
teams
and people you know cheer for them or
root against them and they you know it's
it's it's if if we want to achieve
deep decarbonization of the global
economy we need all the tools on the
table is my view um
every energy technology has risks
and i know you know people that are of
my parents generation the
environmentalists of the 60s and 70s
developed very strong anti-nuclear views
you know richard nixon proposed that the
united states would have a thousand
nuclear power plants and you know we
topped out at about a hundred um if we
had a thousand we'd be a lot closer to
decarbonizing um there's there's
nuclear technology is like any
technology it can advance it can improve
there's plans for modular nuclear
reactors and shipping containers that
can power a small city and so on um
so yes i absolutely think that nuclear
power has a role to play if we look at
japan germany vermont california places
that are shutting down or have shut down
nuclear power plants it gets replaced
with fossil fuels
and and
that increases carbon dioxide emissions
it's perfectly legitimate for people to
be afraid of this or that technology
but politically people have to decide am
i more afraid of
climate risks or am i more afraid of
nuclear power risks because guess what
they kind of trade off right now because
nuclear power
is
one of the technologies that delivers an
enormous
bang for the buck bang for the land use
for addressing carbon dioxide
and
do you would you agree that the risks of
nuclear energy have been uh overstated
they're often overstated absolutely um
and and and you know if you look at what
happened you know three mile island
chernobyl um fukushima
the the these were you know
horrible disasters but if you look at
you know how many people invisibly die
from particulate air pollution every
year
you know the consequences of those
disasters is minuscule compared to the
consequences of burning coal and natural
gas
what um you know how does china in
particular obviously china and india are
the two you know
most populous countries on the planet
and china in particular
is now you know a geopolitical threat or
it's you know and many people in the
american kind of uh you know uh
political class are kind of pushing for
a new cold war with china china's you
know is our counterpart blah blah blah
um does the environmentalist movement or
the decarbonization movement is part of
it kind of working through its uh fear
and anxiety about china trying to get
you know the developing world or china
in particular to um give up you know
it's proven energy resources in things
like coal and and fossil fuels or you
know how how much of i guess
environmental concerns for the
developing world and for china is
actually geopolitics masquerading as
kind of empathy
yeah i mean it's an interesting question
i see often in environmental discussions
um
i mean i don't know if it's the opposite
but but the idea that well let's just be
friends with china um because we're
gonna need to cooperate for you know
you see this in some of john kerry's
discussions that you know climate change
is too important to allow geopolitics to
get in the way and i think that's a
little bit fanciful because geopolitics
is always there um i think it's probably
more healthy
for the environmental community to to
embrace the realities of the global
economy
in which the united states and its
workers are going to be competing with
workers in china elsewhere in india
to produce the energy systems that are
going to power
all of africa southeast asia i mean the
the energy economy is going to continue
to expand
um and
they're going to be winners and losers
in that economic development and whether
it's china's belton road program or
joe biden's buildback better or whatever
we have to understand that um
that it is in our interest
to develop the technologies and forget
about climate change um we want
high-paying jobs we want people um who
are making a lot of money
in our economy that's good for politics
somebody's going to be building
the grids installing nuclear power
plants solar wind in places around the
world
and the argument i would make you know
if i'm a politician is you know let's
make that americans
not chinese not indians and so on um and
then you have more of a virtuous cycle
of course the the
the the military geopolitical overlay on
you know global power is always going to
be there um and i don't you know i don't
think that's that's
going to supplant or or displace these
these economic forces um which also will
always be there
um as a final uh question what what are
the best ways rhetorically uh you know
your your vision of what's going on is a
comforting one it's it's non-alarmist um
you know uh while being you know
explicitly environmentalist in your
concerns
what are the best ways to reach people
who are very committed to the idea that
you know there is a a kind of on off
switch that we're approaching you know
that like the internet meme the finger
is getting closer and closer to the red
button where you know the earth is just
boiling in its own juices and and it's
all over what is the best way to
convince people that what we're actually
talking about is a kind of gradient upon
which
uh temperature or climate is going to be
changing temp or temperatures are going
to be going up but that this you know
it's it's not yes or no it's not on or
off but rather it's you know it's
dealing with
um you know a kind of scenario where
things gradually change and get better
or worse and that we adapt uh as well as
kind of change how we're uh you know uh
actually impacting the universe or the
the environment
yeah i mean it's a fantastic question
i'm probably not the best person to
answer it because i found that the
people on the apocalypse side and the
people on the hope side
take up a lot of the oxygen in this
issue
the reality is that that's not where
policy is actually made
and so i tend um
to to gravitate away from those extremes
on both sides um and when you start
talking to people about uh real policy
and people who are involved in making
real policy around the world um there is
an enormous appetite for a more grounded
a more pragmatic
approach to climate policy so i i am i'm
actually very optimistic that um we're
well positioned that we're making good
progress and if you're you know if your
view of the world is
you know
you know the extreme right or the
extreme left or you spend all your time
on social media you could get a very
different perspective than that but i
think that
you know very much like the population
debates of the 1970s which were also
very extreme
we didn't move past those debates
because people on the extremes got
convinced of anything we moved past
those debates because the evidence from
the real world became undeniable that
you know we got this yeah are there
hungry people yeah there sure are
there's still you know 700 million
hungry people around the world but are
we doing better and moving in the right
direction yes
and so
i think the population debate is a good
model for how the climate debate might
evolve because then you know it's not
gonna it's not gonna end with the with a
bang it's gonna end with a whimper and
and pretty soon um
you know we're going to see
uh oh it's true less people are dying
from extreme weather oh we're still
proof you know producing food our energy
system is changing
is is climate change a threat and has
this yes um does population create
pressures yes
um but uh you know as as we go forward i
think that the evidence of the real
world will
help us to move on to fight about
something else loudly that's not climate
change
roger pelkey jr thanks for talking to
reason
thanks for having me nick